Yeah, the
bouquet flower is another one that has already been completed like this.
Everyone admits that it is beautiful. It's my understanding that there is a symbol of Belgium and a symbol of life
.  By modifying it, it will be something that makes it even more
surprising, or
it will be transformed into life itself.
[Music]
My name is Toshin. I am
also engaged in expression activities using flowers. It's been
20 years ago.  It's a story, but it happened that I was
originally a rock rock band and I couldn't eat it with just music,
so it was a flower shop that I found and hired at that part-time job.
This is a project to fly flowers into the universe. Well, I'm
receiving fireworks in a place where there can never be a hard-liner
.  I wonder what it would be like to receive a flower coming.
Starting from the original idea and
trying to realize it this time
[Music]
It is a project that will continue in various places
tomorrow tomorrow downtown la to downtown
First of all, how about buying flowers at the flower market of Writer's? I bought about 1500 to 1500
volumes of
flowers. Well, I mainly choose flowers of this time, but I talk to flowers and pay.
I think it will be strange in the end when I use it together with the ring. I will
welcome you to the Lovelock Desert
.
So
, this time, I want to give a flower with a height of 30,000 meters above the English translation,
and I think I should take it a little higher.
[Music] By the
way, about 30,000 mares above 30,000.  It's about launching to a meter, so after all it's a
balloon. Well, it's about making something that actually lists the flower.
The next process is to
record it only in the video.  I packed up the technical parts, and
at the end I actually made one flower work by combining the flowers I bought at the Ross flower market in the desert
.  It's a delicate thing, so it's really clean until the end.
I don't know if it's really scattered in outer space, but it's a
really experimental work, so I don't know until I actually go and check the work.
It's
[music]
[applause]
I think it's really fun to say that the cabinet is an art using one flower
.
[Music]
me
After all, this is absolutely  The purpose of selling is to take off the new beauty of the skin by receiving flowers that cannot exist there,
or to guide them to come out.
[Music]